Reggie Miller Hall of Famer Turner
Sports NBA analyst reg on the call with
Kevin Harlan this Thursday night at
10:30 Eastern on TNT the 76ers at the
Warriors and red joins us down kind of a
interesting last 24 hours there reg what
do you make of all of this Anthony Davis
stuff well I didn't we kind of see the
writing on the wall you know as soon as
he had signed with clutch sports and
rich Paul I think we all knew you know
we probably couldn't say it publicly but
we knew that his Anthony Davis time in
New Orleans was going to be limited and
[Music]
though last week and you said you know
there's I'm hearing something there you
know but we didn't know to what degree
but it felt like you thought that
something there was you know impending
doom here for the pelicans with Anthony
Davis look it's been a tough 10 days for
New Orleans
it really has between you know salt and
and then now you have arguably the best
player in franchise history warming out
if you're a resident of Norland is very
difficult but now I'm gonna wear two
hats here for 18 years and a
small-market it saddens me because how
our smaller markets ever going to
compete with the big boys
so I'm saddened at that aspect but then
I put my media hat on and what people
want to know most of the time did he win
a championship did he compete at the
highest level and if Anthony Davis wants
to compete for a championship it's not
going to be in New Orleans he's gonna
have to go to Boston LA so Golden State
that's just what it is
the media and fans alike it's nice that
I played 18 years in one organization
people say that all the time so people
also say but you never won a
championship and I think that's what
these guys are starting to
and as much as we want to pile on KD
leaving OKC being up 3-1 against the
defending champs and then losing and in
the very next season you know jumping on
a plane and heading to San Francisco
he's won back-to-back champion
championships and been Finals MVP twice
so his legacy I think that's what he
wants to build so I don't want to hear
about all where's the loyalty in sports
I get it I understand it hurts me trust
me it does sicken me because there's no
way these smaller markets can't compete
but you guys can't flip it and say what
did he ever win a championship yeah well
he wants to win and compete for a
championship and I think that's what
we're saying
okay what's the Lakers game plan what
would your game plan be if your Magic
Johnson I would call rich Paul and say
how can this happen I would call New
Orleans what do you want we'll give you
everyone other than LeBron James what
the rowing Rob palinka if you want to
well throw in Laker Girls if you want
whoa what is it going to take for us to
get Anthony Davis and if I'm Anthony
Davis and rich Paul do you want Boston
in play here because Boston is not in
play until the offseason how badly do
you want to get to LA or do you really
want to see the Oakland organ think
about this we're gonna have Kevin Durant
Steph Curry LeBron James Russell
Westbrook Paul George all in the Western
Conference if Anthony Davis goes there
think about it think about all the stars
that are out west there is no parity
anymore which is another thing that gets
on my nerves the Eastern Conference is
just decimated but it's also bad for
ratings reg the ratings are down and you
have yes so the West Coast games and and
I said at the beginning of the year they
should start the Laker games earlier
just because you want to bring in the
East Coast audience and we've seen you
know there's no tune in must-see factor
East Coast basketball again it's a
I get it I understand it ad and I can't
fault that you know I had piled on with
Kevin Durant when he first made that
movie I thought it was a sucker move but
I understand it and I understand why he
did it and he's he's right I mean I
don't think they would have ever won a
championship with him in Westbrook in
OKC so he made a business decision and
it is a business people and he is one of
those players that are he's a legacy
player when we think of Kevin Durant won
the game when his career is done he's a
legacy player LeBron a legacy player and
right now his late he is building a heck
of a resume and I get it but it feels
like this is all the bronze so LeBron
and his agent his agent represents
Anthony Davis so LeBron is sort of you
know the puppeteer you know he's the one
that's going okay I think we're gonna
get rid of Luke Walton I don't have any
loyalty to any of these young kids I
want to get an Anthony Davis in here
because Anthony can help me win at least
one more title my window of opportunity
is I probably got four more years here
to win maybe one or two more titles it
feels like that's what's going on behind
the scenes what do you make of that I
will I will say this LeBron and Anthony
Davis alone will not win a championship
they will need a third person now if you
get Anthony Davis and then you're able
to get like a klay Thompson the shooter
now you're into the discussion but to
get Anthony Davis you're gonna have to
give the give away everyone after that
it depends on the supporting players
after that David snow reg I can get that
third person right you you can't you can
but let me say this what is going on now
it's going to put so much pressure on my
mentor when I was at UCLA in Magic
Johnson because this past offseason
Paul George didn't even want to take a
meeting or a call from the hall-of-famer
this is a lot of pride instead the
Lakers are on the clock this season I
said the Lakers are really on the clock
this coming summer they got the big fish
in
Braun but how can now now magic how can
you attract kauai clay boogie cousins
now Anthony Davis how are you going to
be able to get these free agents because
your magic Johnson you have that
megawatt smile you have the
championships
can you bring these guys in to play with
LeBron and possibly Anthony Davis but
after you Davison well and LeBron James
are not going to want to championship
they need that third player talking to
Reggie Miller the Hall of Famer ease
with Kevin Harlan Thursday night 10:30
Eastern on TNT 76ers at the Warriors you
know the boogie cousins experiment is
work quite nicely for Golden State
doesn't doesn't seem fair but is there
any is there anything to keep an eye on
any issues with this team as we breeze
through to the playoffs
well success breeds a lot of things and
that is going to be once boogie Cousins
gets his his game legs right now he's
four or five games into this coming back
from Achilles surgery he doesn't have
his game legs and they're playing them
anywhere between 18 to you know 24
minutes depending on style trouble and
so forth but once he gets in shape Steve
Kerr and they like to use that small
death line up as they call it with
draymond Green at 5:00 a lot of times
Kevon Looney who started all the way up
until boogie cousins came back they'd
like to play Kevon Looney those closing
minutes because they feel he's better
defensively how will DeMarcus handle
that being on the bench in closing
moments when he's an all-star and he's
looking let's face it to get paid next
season will he be able to accept that
role from all indications from when I
hear coming out of warriors camp he is
all on board and it looks like that and
I agree with you it's not fair but it's
how the system is was set up but I want
to see how he handles not being on the
bench come end of April starting into
the playoffs when they go to that small
lineup and he is not on
for yeah that's that's a good take by
the way Shaq I think is stopping by on
Thursday do you think Shaq has any
football ability whatsoever in what term
depends - third offense like what he's a
heck of an offensive lineman right could
I throw him you know woody do you think
he's good he could he throw a football
I'm sure you get throw a football
perfect spiral probably not I'd be more
interested if you could catch a football
yeah it was a big myth though well we're
gonna find out you guys have like a real
quarterback there to see if he can
actually catch some balls he could catch
a round ball I know that I'm the
quarterback Reggie I'm gonna bring some
heat on Thursday to Shaq I can't wait to
see this oh my goodness oh my god one
two trust me I know you always want to
take on somebody always you do not if
you've never been around Shaq like you
he looks big
I mean he really looks big but when he's
in person it's like nothing it almost
looks like they you created this you
know in green screen or 3d or something
like Spielberg created this is what it
feels like when you're around Chuck like
he's just and what's funny and what's
funny gentlemen as big as Theodore is
describing how big Shaq is the year that
yamin made the Hall of Fame and he asked
Shaq to you know walk him in ya swallow
Jack that those are the two biggest
human beings on the planet as we speak
and as big every time I see Shaq I mean
I'm like I can't believe I had to said
screens on this dude
and really 5g I have no video we look
for video of you setting a screen on
Shaq and we could not find any now you
might have to go back to skinny Shack
when he was in Orlando with penny
because when I had to do it in the
finals in 2000 I went to Larry Bird and
said look I screamed on that 395 pound
man and Ricky's not gonna shoot the
basketball are you on the Rams bandwagon
are you like a faux Rams fan on Super
Bowl Sunday
absolutely not here and I'm gonna tell
you why number one my 118 growing up was
the LA Raiders Ken Stabler Lester Hayes
so I'm a number one Raiders fan so
obviously we never rooted for the Rams
and my one B team 18 years in Indiana
Peyton Manning and the Indianapolis
Colts who always went head to head with
Tom Brady and New England so I could
care less about these two teams I don't
care who wins I'm watching the Super
Bowl for the commercials that's harder
[ __ ] okay that's it I could care less
well cam it's not the Raiders and if
it's not the Colt I could care less
all right Thursday night could not care
less
let me get that right I could not care
less yeah people always make that
mistakes because if I guess I could care
less that means you could write you care
a little bit Thursday night 10:30
Eastern on TNT the 76ers at the Warriors
good luck selling that one yeah but
Jimmy Butler's out hopefully he'll be
back hopefully but you still get indeed
right doesn't be a yogi you know it'd be
great maybe Ben Simmons attempts of
three home I will die if he ever makes
the three on air I'm telling you I'm
dropping
my head says walking on it to the floor
and I'm giving him a hug if he misses
the redraw a nine-game I'm stopping the
broadcast reg I said attempt two three
I didn't say make it if he makes the
three do you realize a couple years ago
I said to Brook Lopez would you shoot a
three for me in the all-star game and he
did at the very end and now look at him
he's made at least one three and I think
thirty consecutive games
I changed a man's life Reggie I did it
and I can do it with Ben Simmons and
right now you're putting it into the
universe revenge Simmons I like it or I
like it and I helped him hook up with a
Jenner which what that wasn't as hard
that's him trying to make it three but I
can you're the matchmaker to the Stars
right now you hook those two you know
what I got a rap is it time to go to
commercial break gotta go I'd love to
get in that with you reg but I can save
travels and I'll talk to you soon Thank
You Theadora and I love you then that's
great energy in that building with the
fans there you guys are awesome that's
ready for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]